Del just smashed earnings, suggesting
the AI overbuild is nowhere close to
[music] finishing, which has been
consistent with the thesis given that we
really believe that the money coming
from SpaceX and other companies is going
to keep going into this vortex, whether
it's the anthropic IPO or money raising,
debt financing, whatever, it's all just
going to kind of keep cycling into these
AI hardware companies. Dell is the
recipient of some of that sucking. They
suck money out of the financial system
to invest in capital expenditures. Dell
picks some of that up. Nvidia picks some
of that up. The hardware 2.0 cycle which
has been struggling with a lack of
liquidity and fear over JPO and well
Kevin Worsh and rates
that sucking is sending money to the
hardware plays and eventually should
drive a hardware 2.0 rally. Although we
were delayed a little bit because again
those the you know rate concerns and
worsh. So what did we just get out of
Dell and what's so interesting about it?
Dell just reported uh revenues uh that
beat expectations across the board. We
got Q3 revenue guide up 16.9%.
Which is really good. The AI optimized
server forecast uh came in 23% higher
than expected at 74 billion versus 60.
And this was really the showstopper.
Their fiscal year earnings per share
forecast came in 42%
higher than expected, which is insane.
Instead of $17.9
per share uh on uh 17.8 17.9 in that
rough midpoint range for adjusted EPS
next year or for the uh yeah, for the
fiscal year uh ending January 2027.
Their fiscal year is a little funky. Uh
instead of 17.8 to 17.9, they're
expecting to have adjusted EPS of
$25.50.
2550. Come on, man. This is a massive
beat of 42% on their forecast buy
online. Now, that is adjusted EPS. So,
there could be some funky math going on
there. So, what I wanted to do was go
deep in uh dig deep into their margins
because I've always thought of Dell as a
relatively low margin infrastructure
play. And you all kind of have my
mindset on where infrastructure plays
it. You've you've seen this before.
We've got this little paper we keep
right here. Uh and we believe that over
time infrastructure commoditizes, tokens
commoditize, and the value enhancers
win. I like investing where the value
enhancers are, but I'm not saying I
think there's the end to the
infrastructure cycle yet because there's
so much money going from the big money
raises and the sucking into
infrastructure. So, I actually think
there's still another cycle here just
delayed again by Warsh and all the other
nonsense. Um, by the way, in case you're
wondering what this is, if you want the
Meet Kevin app, you can get that for
free. Keep in mind, you can get that on
desktop as well. Just make sure you
download the mobile Android or Apple app
first. Sign up, use your course member
email if you're a course member,
otherwise just create an account if
you're not. Uh, and it's free to use the
app. And then you can use app.mmeke.com,
which is kind of cool because then you
can kind of get the wire services up.
And uh uh for example, one of the things
that I did is I typed in Dell into the
search function right here. And then I
could see some of the Dell commentary
coming straight out of the earnings call
without having to actually listen to the
earnings call. This is just a quick
trick if you want to do that. I still
personally like going to the earnings
calls, but it saves a lot of time and I
like things that save time. But talking
about margins, so I've always thought of
Dell as a historically low margin
business. And since 2020, they really
have been. Go back to 2020, you see,
they lost money. Uh, okay fine. It was
COVID. 2021 2.3% margins. 2022 23 24 25
basically between 4.2 to 4.8% margins.
Low. But look at the expectations of
what's happening to their margins. 2026
5.7 2027 7.1 terminating at about 8.2 in
2031 based on current analyst
expectations. this jump between 25 and
26 uh and then this jump up to January
of 2027. All these dates, by the way,
end in January, which is again their
sort of weird fiscal calendar, but
whatever. 5.7
from 4.8 represents an 18.9%
18.8% growth. And if I go 17.1 divided
by 5.7, that represents a 24 12% growth
rate. So these net income margins are
popping off and that's one of the
reasons there's so much enthusiasm on
the earnings report coming from Dell
because we're finding that a relatively
low margin provider is actually
contributing uh substantial bottomline
boosts uh for Dell. So, if I jump on
over to their infrastructure group,
which is where you're going to see the
artificial intelligence servers, you'll
find here that AI optimized servers saw
a doubling from last year. Now,
interestingly, that growth was only
1.67%
from the last quarter. See, I pulled up
their last earnings report, and AI
optimized servers ending May 1st sat at
16.1 billion. And in this quarter, they
sat at 16.4 billion. So, you're kind of
starting to run into some of those large
number concerns, but the EPS growth is
what's making people really excited
about the stock. I personally flag this
as a little bit of a red flag. And I
want to be clear, I do not have an
exposure long or short to Dell. Just
sharing, you know, my sort of reaction
to this. Uh I did see that in this
quarter traditional servers and storage
grew more at 122% and 26% whereas in the
last quarter they were growing at 92%
and 8%. So both of those segments
actually grew nicely leading to an 89%
increase in that infrastructure group
revenue. Uh last quarter higher growth
rate because of that growth uh you know
that like 700% growth rate in AI
optimized servers. So a little bit of a
slowdown quarterto quartarter uh here in
AI optimized servers you are running
into the law of large numbers but what's
fascinating isn't the law of num large
numbers problem what's fascinating is
their pricing power their uh percentage
of operating income as a percentage of
net income so after costs is now 15%
for the infrastructure solutions group
it used to be 8.8% 8%. So they had to go
sell a server to somebody and they'd
bring bring 8.8% to operating income.
Now they're bringing nearly twice that
to operating income. Okay, I might be
generous with twice. They are bringing
70% more. That's really good. So that
margin pop is fascinating. People love
that. that margin pop could be
justifying this boost we're seeing in
Dell's uh forecast for adjusted EPS. But
I didn't just want to look at the
infrastructure solutions group. So I
wanted to see if their pricing power is
growing elsewhere. If I look at their
margin growth on products, the answer is
yes. We are generating more revenues
than our products are costing us. That's
an increase in pricing power. Plus, when
we compare total revenue growing at 58%
or even just products growing at 72%.
And then we look at gross margin growth
of 80%. We can see that 80% their gross
margin is greater than what their
revenue growth is, which means they're
taking more pricing. You can also look
at it in the inverse by looking at their
costs which are growing slower than
their actual uh revenues are growing. Uh
which is great. both both products
services were actually negative over
here. They spent less money on services.
So you've got this expanding gross
margin. Those are all signs of pricing
power. Is it possible this is all a
temporary bubble? Of course. Of course.
Like you know, like I said, I think we
got one more good euphoric rally and
then I think Anthropic ruins everyone's
day. Not right when they IPO, but when
they report their first and second and
third quarter earnings as they're public
and people start going, "Ah,
really? That's not that good." You know,
the more that starts happening, that's
when, you know, some of the spending
slows down a little bit and the hardware
hype kind of dies. I still think there's
a hype cycle between now and them. But
Dell is actually really unique because
Dell doesn't actually sell to the
hyperscalers.
Dell focuses their sales on the
sovereigns, the Neoclouds, uh, and then
also uh, the the enterprise businesses.
I'm a really really big fan of
enterprises using artificial
intelligence. I I I don't want to sound
like a broken record. talk about it in
almost every single freaking video, but
we just look at what we can do with
artificial intelligence and provide
those services, whether it's our homes
AI product or uh you know, our stock
terminal product uh or just what we're
building. It's so incredible with
artificial intelligence. We're really
excited about it. The reason I bring
that up is is not to shield anything.
It's it's simply to say we've blown more
money on hardware than I think I ever
have at any point in my career. Right?
And because like the money we're
spending on hardware is generating
money. And that's literally what Dell
said at their top line. If you look at
Dell's top line, they say, and it's
totally true, it environments have
shifted from cost centers to value
drivers that fuel growth and competitive
advantages, and customers are investing
accordingly, creating opportunities
across the Dell portfolio. Yeah. Yeah. I
totally totally agree. You know, you
could see some of our products like if
you go to the meet reinvest uh page uh
extended through Friday, you have one
more shot here to get in for that
lifetime access because Teachable had a
payment glitch when our coupon expired
last Friday. You can get lifetime access
to the Reinvest Homes AI product. Uh and
then you could also, of course, get
lifetime access to the Meet Kevin
membership, online courses, every trade
alert, every private live stream, every
alpha report. Just use that coupon code
J-Hold before the end of the day on
Friday. Tax professionals say it could
be a tax writeoff. Now, let's think
about what that means for Dell. What
that means is across the board, you have
customers going to Dell saying, "Hey, we
don't really care what it costs." I
mean, there's obviously some limit, but
enterprise businesses, that's a little
redundant, businesses are going to Adele
and they're saying, "We want AI servers
in our business. Help us set them up. We
don't want to go buy the graphics card
ourselves. We don't want to hire the
engineers to build the software to run
it. you give us the software, you give
us the hardware, plug it in, and tell me
I have an AI data server. Dell will do
that for you. And that's what's kind of
cool. Now, the CEO says they have spotty
CPU shortages uh and shortages with disk
drives as well. Uh keep in mind, this is
on the stock tab for course members in
the alpha membership. They expect that
75% of all data center demand will be
artificial intelligence by 2030. I don't
actually see that as an issue mostly
because I think we're just kind of
transitioning away from a normal server
to a server that can basically do AI and
non AI tasks. It's just sort of like the
next generation server, right? Uh they
say here the second half they think will
be even stronger than the first half. I
think that's a little bit of explaining
for that slowdown in the quarter
overquarter growth rate. I think that
quarter over-arter growth rate like not
year-over-year but comparing to last
quarter was a little weird. like really
it only grew to about 1%. Okay,
whatever. Uh like really one of the few
red flags I found. Uh big refresh
opportunity they say for older 14th
generation servers and before that. Uh
and then uh you know the fiscal year
forecast for earnings were 42% too low.
And that actually helps us look at
evaluation. And this is the hardest
thing about fundamental analysis is you
kind of have to compare your
expectations for growth to what analysts
are projecting. And analysts can be
wrong to the upside, they could be wrong
to the downside. It's obviously the
problem with that. So if we look at
where this company sits right now based
on analyst expectations, it's sitting at
a growth rate of about 16.3 with a price
to earnings ratio of about
uh let's see if we take 1910 for the end
of the year. Now revised numbers that
puts us at about uh 24 times. So right
now we're trading for somewhere around
divided by 16.3 actually trading for
only about 1.49. 49 on a PEG ratio.
That's after these last earning sets uh
come in. So this number really drove
some meaningful change to that that Dell
bottom line. Uh so I'm going to modify
this uh in terms of the EPS that's
currently projected. We've got 19 or I'm
just going to write this down. We've got
10 uh and then the growth rate analysts
expect 16%. But remember, if the
forecast is that we're actually going to
be about 42% higher on earnings,
then we might actually be growing closer
to 23%.
If we adjust that in, the peg for this
company all of a sudden looks a lot more
inexpensive and it looks like the
company has more potential upside.
Because if I now come in here and say,
"All right, we're going to say growth is
23%.
We're going to give it a 1.4 peg at uh
the EPS for the for January. We could
potentially get to a price target range
between 527 to 615."
Now, there's something really important
about that. That target range assumes
that we could keep beating estimates
that all estimates between now and 2030
should get jacked up by about 42%.
That might be too aggressive.
Unfortunately, if you discount away that
42%,
the stock shouldn't really go anywhere,
right? You kind of suggest with these
latest earnings, it's actually his
earnings were really good. they're
making a whole lot more money, but now
the stock has already priced that in.
The last time we looked at Dell, we're
like, "Ah, they're a little pricey." You
know, the markets are expecting bigger
growth and we got that. So, last time
we're like, man, you know, these
earnings, these estimates, they're
they're really low. All of a sudden, we
get these crazy earnings. It's like
stock blows up, you know, 6% or
whatever. Blows people's expectations
out of the water. That's great. Stocks
up now 7%. You're sitting at about 455.
If we look at this on a technical basis,
we could see we're pretty dang close to
the top over here. Uh let's go down.
We'll take the 2025
uh in this case, we'll take the 2025
bottom and we'll just do a quick
technical look at it. If I take
and 6473 here.
Okay, lock that into place. Look at
where we're sitting. We're literally
jumping off of that 417 line that we've
consistently been rubber banding around.
So, a durable place to bounce on. More
preferable to buy it around these
levels. It's possible because the market
is a little tenuous between now and Fed
day. maybe you'll be able to get a
discount for this again. But the flip
side is you really have to expect those
big growth rates to justify the forward
valuation on this. So maybe you do maybe
you think enterprise AI is going to last
a whole lot longer, boom, a whole lot
more than the hyperscaler uh AI demand.
I don't disagree with that argument. Uh
I think there's a risk that if
hyperscaler demand goes away, all stocks
kind of fall in the hardware space. But
enterprise might be a whole lot more
durable. Uh, so I like the enterprise
spending, but I will make a note here
that a five, what do we say? Five, this
is on the low end for margins. 1.2 peg
versus 1.4 peg puts us out 527 to 615.
517 to 615 uh terminal price target uh
requires
uh about 23% average EPS growth. That
might be frothy. Uh enterprise might
rush to AI the next few years but will
terminal growth rates hold up right
uh rates hold up because if the terminal
growth rate for this ends up at 10%. You
know then then we get to really pricey
again at these lower 8% margins. So
bottom line, growth really beat
expectations here. Yes, some nervousness
in markets now, but the spend is still
going on like crazy.
That's good for now and uh honestly good
for Dell. [music] They are making way
more money on a low margin product than
uh than markets expected. [music] Uh and
it's very impressive. I hope they keep
it going. All right, that's Dell. Why
not advertise these things that you told
us here? I feel like nobody else knows
about this.
>> We'll we'll try a little advertising and
see how it goes.
>> Congratulations, man. You have done so
much. People love you. People look up to
you.
>> Kevin Praath there, financial analyst
and YouTuber. Meet Kevin. Always great
to get your take.